et on continue notre état des lieux de
la région avec ce soir deux cantons
présidentielle oui deux cantons de
présidents de conseils généraux en
commençant par la saône et loire et le
canton de louhans qui est le canton de
rémi chaintron le président socialiste
du conseil général mais qui était aussi
pour partie celui d'arnaud montebourg il
y a donc du symbole dans l'air et du
suspens après la prise de la ville de
louhans par la droite aux dernières
municipales
damien guti est remis à chaque réunion
les visites de chantier rémi chaintron
continue de les enchaîner car même si sa
mandature arrive à son terme
l'actuel président du conseil général de
saône et loire ne lâche rien il met
cependant régulièrement ses fonctions
entre parenthèses pour faire campagne
car il compte bien être réélu et
pourquoi pas gardé la présidence
aujourd'hui la gauche au niveau national
n'a pas forcément le vent en poupe mais
les gens ont bien compris que dans ce
département nous avions bien géré ce
département nous avons pas fait de
fiscalité de ces cinq dernières années
nous avons désendetter de 24 % sur la
même période le département et nous
avons fait surtout des choses utiles à
leur quotidien et ça je sais que l'essm
et loirienne saône et loiriens les
bressans les bressane seront sans céder
et le challenge est de taille car avec
le redécoupage des cantons
rémi chaintron des font désormais la
gauche sur les terres d'élection
d'arnaud montebourg
impossible que ce bastion bascule c'est
tout un symbole alors comme colistière
c'est sabine schaeffer qui
l'accompagnent elle est la mère de
montrer ville où l'ancien ministre a une
maison on se revendique forcément de
l'héritage arnaud montebourg dans la
mesure où lorsqu'il est arrivé à la
présidence du conseil général
il a aussi été très actif en ce qui
concerne la revalorisation des
territoires forcément à droite on veut
tourner la page chanteront monde
et l'ump avec le slogan vous être utile
présente deux candidats trentenaire dont
la présidente des jeunes populaires de
saône et loire
je suis adjointe au maire de simard
c'était une élection qui était bien
différent qui n a pas la même pas la
même ampleur
et c'est vrai que c'est une première
élection un premier challenge et je
censure très réjouissant son colistier
ton tony vadot il se présente sans
étiquette mais forcément avec des
affinités à droite
particularité il fut le plus jeune maire
de bourgogne et c'est un proche du
député européen ump arnaud danjean
j'étais effectivement ce plan d' arnaud
labbe et 17 yves en 2012 après le fait
que je sois un peu identifiée au niveau
de noir ainsi que les communes autour
voilà je me sens légitime a essayé de
représenter au mieux ces territoires
sur les panneaux électoraux tous les
partis n'ont pas encore coller leurs
affiches
c'est le cas du front national car pour
cause agenda les candidats font campagne
principalement le week end
ainsi s'est aidée par son mari que marie
reverchon rempiler boîte aux lettres en
semaine pour présenter le binôme qu'elle
forme avec jean philippe hurteau moi je
pense que ça pourrait bien se passer on
est très bien reçu quand on tracte les
gens sont très sympas avec nous donc à
la fois pourquoi pas aller jusqu'au bout
le risque chez les abstentionnistes on a
un peu peur de ça enfin je pense que
toutes les leçons tous les partis encore
des abstentionnistes et jean traitant de
nous aussi les autres partis au soir des
résultats
le canton de lyon sera donc
particulièrement observés et autres
président en campagne c'est andré
villiers dans l'yonne
oui on sait que l'avis de la droite est
tumultueuse dans l'yonne puisque lui dit
andré villiers a pris la présidence du
conseil général à l'ump mais dans son
canton qui s'appelle désormais joux la
ville et qui regroupe les anciens canton
de vézelay et de vermenton les choses
s'annoncent plus facile à droite il
devra en revanche affronter deux binômes
de gauche et le front national qui
espère accéder au deuxième tour
basis djaouti et claude d'un scrutin
binominal rien changé
expliquer rappeler aux électeurs
l'importance du scrutin départemental et
les inciter à voter
andré villiers est en campagne
accompagnée de sa nounou colette lerman
le président centriste du conseil
général enchaîne les réunions et
sillonne les communes de l'yonne comme
ici le petit village de précis le sec
près de joux la ville dans son fief sur
ses terres beaucoup ici le voir élu haut
la main lui s'y refuse il ya quelques
règles pour figurer dans un deuxième
tour qui est de faire obligatoirement
l'issue du premier tour
douze ennemis des inscrits que sera la
participation que sera l'attrait pour
d'autres candidats éventuels donc voilà
c'est extrêmement difficile de répondre
à cette question
moi je n'ai pas d'éléments pour vous
indiquer quel sera le scénario
bonjour monsieur j'espère que vous allez
voter quand on ira voter peser face à
une dizaine de kilomètres gilles
villecourt est lui aussi sur le terrain
candidate de gauche avec françoise et
nogueira soutenue par le ps et le prg
cet ancien maire adjoint ici à vermenton
sait que la tâche sera difficile face au
conseiller général et président sortant
la gauche part désunis mais gilles
villecourt croit pourtant en ses chances
et fustige le bilan d'andré villiers à
la tête du département c'est sûr que si
on était rassemblée on serait beaucoup
plus fort il ya l'usure du pouvoir et
puis il ya un constat un constat qui
donne le département de l'yonne comme le
avant dernier de la france au point de
vue économique
au point de vue économique donc c'est
pas un bon bilan
voici l'autre binôme de gauche raymond
de coulon et andré jérôme eux sont
candidats pour le front de gauche et
europe écologie les verts très important
elle retraité de la poste lui ouvrier
autoroutier il se revendique d'une vraie
gauche qui n'a rien à voir avec le ps ou
le gouvernement actuel le binôme espère
que les électeurs ne s'y tromperont pas
et votre on peut justement parce que
nous nous sommes à gauche voilà nous
sommes à gauche et nous n'avons pas la
même vision de la gauche que le ps nous
n'avons pas les mêmes idées sur les
choses à faire et c'est tout après on a
chacun notre particularité non on fait
pas le jeu unis de villiers n'est du
front national
un front national présent second tour
l'ambition de gérard de martini avec
ludivine bourgeois absente ce jour là le
conseil municipal
avallon nourrit de grandes ambitions
pour ce canton de joux-la-ville le
candidat pour les élections
départementales du front national il ya
un électorat front existence est vrai
depuis nombreuses années sur ces
secteurs parce que ce sont des secteurs
en euros ou le feront un potentiel ya
placé mais il ya on peut aller encore au
delà et il ya des rues d'autres
électeurs encore les trouver à aller
chercher
outre vermenton ou joux-la-ville le
nouveau canton regroupe surtout de
nombreuses petites communes dans ce
territoire rural
le front national mise donc sur un score
élevé mais une défaite d'andré villiers
ancien maire de vézelay très ancré au
niveau local paraît plus qu'improbable
et on trouve aussi des candidats de
l'yonne sur les réseaux sociaux ou les
échanges très vifs entre candidats du
front national et de la droite exemple
ce tweet du candidat frontiste de pont
sur yonne qui assène sur le réseau
social les chiffres des cambriolages
dans le département de l'yonne
des chiffres qui ne correspondent pas
aux compétences des conseils généraux ce
qui entraîne une vive réponse des jeunes
de l'udps et y du département qui parle
de degré zéro les changes a duré un
certain temps aujourd'hui
autre point chaud de la journée nous en
avons déjà parlé dans ce journal la
décision du maire de chalon de supprimer
les menus de substitution dans les
cantines décision qui est placée aussi
dans la perspective des départementales
par la conseillère générale socialiste
françoise verjux qui se demande si cette
mesure préfigure une décision dans les
collèges compétences du conseil général
et puis pour finir en douceur ce tweet
du candidat udi alexandre bouchier qui
se concentre sur des dessins d'enfants
pour se souvenir que la politique c'est
d'abord travailler pour l'avenir on peut
finir là-dessus et prochain journal de
campagne demain ici à la même heure
merci lilian